[Music]
any flaws you have you know I can get
hangry a lot of times we kind of cream
in snippy
you know hangry well they must have kept
it beca
well that because she found love TVs new
bachelorette revealed as she does get
engaged at the end of the season which
begins Monday on ABC but who is more
likely to live happily ever after Becca
and her man or for Terry and make it we
put that exact question to host Chris
Harrison
the royal couple probably has a better
chance only because they have two bats
are about to write couples they have to
live in the real world and so it's
probably tougher for them than it is the
Royals not exactly a vote of confidence
from Chris but when you consider the
last three bachelorettes from the series
are still with her final picks well that
does that feel pretty good a lot of guys
fell in love with Becca and she has a
lot of strong feelings or maybe more
than one man so just who are the 28 guys
vying for Becca's hearts well five of
them are current or former pro athletes
there's a social media participants who
post a lot of shirtless pics and a
Hollywood stunt man who looks like Jason
Momoa he's been growing his hair for ten
years 500 and there's this guy John
Blanc is a Colonna sewer I don't think
that's an actual job but I think it's
250 different scents becca is 28 and the
men range in age from 25 to 30 1 but it
sounds as if some of them aren't
grown-up enough to avoid the drama you
will witness some of the craziest
arguments and incidents that have ever
taken place
this is a lot harder than I thought it
would be oh my oh
listen we know that someone out there
will find true love
[Music]